I really enjoy Nicha. Okay. So anything by Nicha, Frederick nature,
he's a philosopher. Um,
I actually hated him when I first read him in my early twenties.
Let's take the opposite of most people's experience. Right.
They usually love them in their twenties and then they throw them to the curb.
Later. Yeah.
I think he's totally misrepresented and misinterpreted.
Well, it happened in one night. So let me just describe it.
Cause it's kind of funny having on new year's. So I had friends in,
when I was in my twenties and they were kept, they kept telling me,
you have to reteach, you have to reteach it. And I tried. Okay. But again,
you know, no,
I didn't like I was not into how he described the philosophical
concepts he was trying to get across. So, but they would,
they weren't giving up. I very, um, persistent friends.
So one of them gave me, um,
the gay science and I had it on my bookstand
and it was new year's Eve. And I'm actually not a big part.
I'm actually an introvert on the I'm a geeky introvert. Okay.
So I don't go out and party a lot. It was a year new year's Eve.
Even that couldn't get me out to go party.
So I just wanted to go to bed and years Eve hit and everybody went out and I
was asleep and they woke me up and I was like, darn, they woke me up. Eh,
might as well read this book by Nicha. Okay.
So I picked it up and lo and behold,
I turned to a page that was exactly about it was called Sanctus January,
which is basically St. January. And it was about new year's Eve. And I thought,
Whoa, what a weird coincidence. And it was a really,
it was also super Catholic and it was a really beautiful little aphorism.
It's actually a book of aphorisms, which are kind of religious. Right.
And so he beat it's really just, uh, the genres religious let's put it that way,
but he's not. So basically he says,
today's the day when people are supposed to make these resolutions. Right.
And he says, from here on out, I will, will never say no,
I will only say yes. Okay. I look away.
If some of these horrible I'll just look away from it. I won't get angry at it.
And then he also says, I will be like Saint,
January and Saint January is actually the Saint whose blood is in
this place in Italy. I think it's in Italy. And um,
and every year it turns, it turns to blood again. So it's like,
it's desiccated it's, you know, so it's this miracle. It says, my blood is now,
um, it flows again. And I was like, wow, that's really beautiful. And I said,
and a strange coincidence because it just turned, you know, 12.
So it was like new year's Eve. I pick up the book, I read this aphorism. I said,
strange coincidence that,
and then I turn the page and the page is about coincidences. And I was like,
I shut it. And I thought, this is weird. And I felt like there was a lie.
I felt like the book was alive in each was to me. Right.
I had a like experience and engagement with Nisha.
And so after that I couldn't put his stuff down. It was engaging,
fascinating everything. So, yeah. So that's one book, the gay science.
What'd you, what did you pick up from, from uh,
the gay science or from each year in January? Is there some ideas that.
The idea is basically that, um,
truth he's got awesome.
One-liners you know, so truth is a woman, so, okay.
What is it, what does he mean by that truth is a woman. Basically.
She's going to lie to you. She looks real attractive,
but she's not going to tell you the truth.
Yeah.
Okay. So basically I'm not saying that that's true about women.
I'm obviously a woman. So he's,
so basically what he's saying is that truth is not, is like what I say,
brother guy said, it's a moving target. Okay.
We started this whole conversation with what's real. Right.
So I should have just gone straight to Nisha, having not,
you heard truth as a woman.
Okay. So truth.
Is a woman. All right. So that, and also, and you know, food code, this, um,
other philosopher,
French philosopher actually takes up this idea and creates his own
framework or called genealogy from it.
So the genealogy of morals so that we only believe certain things in, we,
we sediment to them into truth. So we say, you know,
a truth told who said that was at Lennon or stolen a truth
told enough times, I mean, a lie told enough times becomes the truth.
Yeah. So that's basically Nietzschean right there. Okay. So that's nature.
So you need to also as a huge critic of Christianity, um,
which I'm actually Catholic, I'm a practicing Catholic. So, uh,
I appreciated his critique. I thought it was actually quite accurate. Um,
he's a critique of religion in general and, and he's fascinating.
And also I find that his,
he talks about altered States of consciousness and he calls them elevated
States. And he, I think through his book,
you can actually experience elevated States. So, um, yeah, Nisha.